neon evangelion genesis a syllable for
every heartbreak apparently i have
repeatedly been told that this is the
greatest anime of all time is that true
well as someone who has watched
six other anime i am fully qualified to
make that decision and the answer is yes
video over uh subscribe to my patreon
links down below it's been great talking
no i'm kidding no i have no idea if it
is yet but that is what we are here to
find out and to help me is little willow
who is being a rascal let's see say
hello to the camera willow i am only
nine episodes out of the 26 into the
series but do tell me what is the best
anime are they right when they've told
me or is there another show that i
should be watching i'm gonna go through
my positives and discuss the world
building and the characters then we're
gonna discuss my negatives and then i'm
gonna look at some predictions of what i
think is gonna happen going forward in
the series so
this show was sold to me as a brilliant
exploration of uh you know child trauma
and the horrors of war it that it wasn't
just kind of like a flashy sci-fi uh you
know story with with cool makers and
kaiju but then it was a a complex
exploration of really deep ideas and
that is definitely
my ballpark i'm there for that sort of
thing so imagine my shock when i got to
the episode where our main characters
are literally told to defeat this alien
kaiju we must literally have a dance
party because apparently the only way to
kill this particular alien monster
is by working together perfectly in sync
and the only way that they can possibly
learn that
is by learning a dance routine you know
like one of those like old ps2 games
where you're like standing on the mat or
or whatever yeah literally that either
way i gotta admit at nine episodes in i
thought it would be darker than this it
was kinda sold to me as a darker show
but it's been pretty light-hearted for
the most part so far
and i do really like dark stories so i
hope kind of going forward into the next
two thirds of the series
that some darker elements might come to
light uh that'd be really cool but so
far neon evangelion genesis has been
fantastic i immediately bought into this
world this world that has been ravaged
by an asteroid disaster of some kind
called the second impact it's not quite
a
post-apocalyptic world at least
not in the way that people typically
imagine though it clearly has had a lot
of people die
but you know the oceans have risen
entire cities are underground or
underwater and these alien kaiju which
they call angels are attacking the
cities of humanity
and so
naturally in response as humanity always
would we create giant mecca to fight
them that can of course only be piloted
by children neon evangelion genesis is
basically pacific rim or i suppose
pacific rim is basically neon evangelion
genesis and there is some really cool
world building in the first episode uh
one of those kaiju were coming to
destroy a city and it drops into the
earth like they slot into this
underground bunker of sorts i don't
think i've ever seen something on that
scale before but it was really cool to
see
um also it did come out out in 1995 all
right and it may be one of those times
where you know sci-fi didn't quite
manage to predict what sort of
technology we would have in the future
but these giant
mecca robots that fight these kaiju uh
have to run by a chord like they've got
a power chord in the back so they can
only fight within a certain radius
and i thought that was quite funny
but let's talk about the characters
because they are fantastique i just met
asuka or asuka her name is asuka and she
is
german apparently
she immediately made an impression on me
within her first couple of minutes i
remembered her name really well
she's explosive but funny and likable
but also quite complex which is really
good she's a great foil for shinji our
other main character uh she's an
experienced pilot in these makers
likewise masato was kind of this cool
mum character and one of the things that
i really liked that they did was you can
feel the age of the characters uh you
can tell by how they talk and how they
act
masato
approaches the fight with the angels
with a kind of seriousness and gravitas
that
the kids
don't necessarily seem to have it's kind
of like you know they're they're a
little bit stuck in their own world
and
that's a really nice contrast in how
they view the stuff that is happening i
do have a criticism about the characters
but i'll get to that in my criticisms
section now you might think that these
children have a huge responsibility
defending humanity and so naturally they
would spend all of their time training
and learning but you would be wrong
because they also go to school i mean
that is an old sci-fi fantasy superhero
trope you know they have their superhero
life and their normal life and they're
trying to balance between them i don't
know where the school storyline is going
because it's not actually in the series
that much it's kind of in the background
and all of our main characters are much
more in that mecca
superhero world there's not really kind
of points attention that you might
normally see you know for example
there's a school dance coming up and
they've got that all to worry about like
shinji doesn't seem to have big school
problems i don't know i'm only nine
episodes in we will see but
if there is one trope that will get me
interested in a story it is this
conspiracies i
love stories that have you know the
secret cabal of of people in the dark
planning something in the background the
end of the episode and they pick up the
phone and they go
everything's going well and then you
don't know who it is and you don't know
who you can trust and the characters are
slowly figuring that out till they're
betrayed by someone
and as far as i can tell neon evangelion
genesis has this in spades i don't know
what it is but there is this guy in a
dark weird room who is giving orders and
getting reports on things and clearly
has a plan coming together and he was
just given a fossil of some kind which
he called the first human
and he called it adam which also by the
way implies the existence of an eve and
i wonder what or who that would be at
the moment it's just a fossil but i did
notice something else there are these
markings on the floor or the ceiling of
this giant room now if you've seen full
meal alchemist brotherhood you will
recognize the huge human transmutation
or just transmutation markings that
appear as a repeated motif throughout
the series it's a formula of some kind
and it really did remind me of that or
perhaps it's a map and importantly i
have seen it in the opening credits and
if i have learned anything about anime
it's that anything in the opening
credits is vitally important so
i'm definitely going to be looking out
for that
if you like you know this kind of story
conspiracies it's the thing that got me
into full metal alchemist brotherhood
then this might be the story for you i
can see why people call it the best
anime series of all time it's pacing is
insanely good and i really do mean that
it's one of the highlights for me every
single scene feels vital and it pulls
you along it feels like it's furthering
the plot and the characters let's be
honest anime has a ton of filler like
attack on titan is fantastic but it took
way too long to do
anything whatsoever especially in those
opening couple of seasons you know
neon evangelion genesis does not have
that problem i am nine episodes in and
it's felt like one the music is
fantastic a real bop
i listen to the opening credits every
single damn time and the art style is
distinctive and beautiful it's really
reminiscent of that era criticisms i
mean i don't really have that many
hello just jumped up onto my lap
i don't really have that many at this
point if the plot is good and the
characters are mostly good and the
pacing is good
you're mostly quibbling over little
details at that point i will note that i
don't like the perving element to the
story it's a trope you see in some anime
like the young male characters will look
at other young girls through binoculars
while they're changing often near
entirely naked um
and it's meant to be i think endearing
or it's meant to be funny
but i personally don't really find it
that funny it makes it difficult to like
them when i think i'm meant to
the one criticism i have to do with the
characters is that i want to know shinji
better he's our main character but for
the most part he's kind of a bit of a
blank slate you know he's being
pulled around all the characters around
him are making the decisions that drive
the plot and i get that the story is
about how these systems
use these children to fight their war
that their pawns their objects in a
sense but at nine episodes in i want to
know more about what he wants and what
he fears and have that play into the
story he actually has this moment in the
first or first couple episodes where he
runs away from this big mecca system
and he goes and hides and sets up a tent
because he doesn't want to be around
this world anymore and to be honest that
is
really really understandable it's
endearing it was great
we haven't really had anything like that
since
and so i want to see a bit more of kind
of those developments predictions number
one i think that we're gonna see some
kind of twist or escalation in the
conflict pretty damn soon now up until
this point it's been a little bit
formulaic there's been you know a bit of
character drama and then there's a new
kaiju that shows up and they have to
work together to defeat it
i think that formula is probably going
to shift we've mostly been introducing
our characters in the world but i think
we're going to move on to that deeper
maybe darker plot that's been hinted at
i had a second prediction and i was very
wrong and i didn't think about it that
much so i'm retracting it and no i'm not
gonna share it with you
three there's gonna be something to do
with eve or adam and eve and there's
gonna be something in the past that
happened that was really important to
evolution or that our development as a
species maybe we arrived on an asteroid
to this planet you know that's that's an
old thing because there's asteroids
um
and the second impact was kind of a big
thing i actually know how the aliens
ended up on the planet to be honest but
uh maybe that's gonna be revealed uh and
also i think that as this conspiracy
kind of gets developed someone we think
we can trust is going to be revealed to
be bad maybe miss masato's boyfriend i
don't know just my guess please do not
spoil things for me in the comments i am
really enjoying it so far do you want to
see
like my review of later episodes
no i i don't know
uh stay nerdy and i will see you in the
future